[Applaudissements]
je vais vous parler de l'histoire de
cette statue on a fait si tu représentes
aussi une partie de ma vie
c'est une statue qui a été inaugurée le
8 mars 2021
dans la maison du sport français au
Comité national olympique et sportifs
français à côté de la statue de
Coubertin et
cette ceinture représente Alice mia
donc qui était Alice Milla
le 5 mai 1884 à Nantes et à partir
habiter à Londres à 20 ans elle a
rencontré Joseph Mia l'employé de
commerce nantais également et s'est
marié là-bas
malheureusement 4 ans plus tard
Joseph décède
et elle revient en France et en
Angleterre elle avait appris à faire du
sport
était une évidence dans la société
anglaise qui était pas dans la société
française
n'étant pas une grande sportive elle a
essayé de faire de l'aviron
et pour ça c'est inscrite à la une
association qui s'appelle féminin sport
dont elle est devenue très rapidement
présidente
entre temps elle a eu le brevet au Dax
le brevet au Dax est un brevet qu'on a
sur qui demande à faire 80 km en avion
sur la Seine dans un temps imparti c'est
la première femme de l'histoire à
l'avoir fait
et
elle a
les deux nous pouvons présents de
féminin sport elle a été également
président de la fondatrice de la
fédération sportive des fédérases des
associations sportives de femmes
de prix également président en 1917
et devant le refus de comité olympique
d'intégrer les femmes au programme
olympique je
vous rappelle la citation de du baron du
chien baron Pierre de Coubertin lors des
Jeux de Stockholm 1912
une Olympia de femelle serait
inapproprié
esthétique
praticable en pratique pardon voire
incorrect le véritable héros olympique
et le Mal individuel je vais faire la
parenthèse
nous devons cette position assez ferme
elle décide d'organiser d'abord des
compétitions nationales le premier je
pense de football en 1919 et Alice Mia
puis international
puisque le 20 août 1922 elle a créé à
Pershing dans le stade Pershing à côté
de Vincennes à côté de Paris les
premiers Jeux Olympiques féminins
le 20 août 1922 dont on a fêté les 100
ans il y a quelques il y a un mois un
mois et demi
et devant le succès
en 1926 les deuxièmes Jeux à Stockholm
le
successeur de Coubertin le baron du bas
de la tour Baillet de la tour pardon a
accepté que les femmes puissent intégrer
les Jeux Olympiques sur cinq épreuves en
athlétisme en 1928 Amsterdam
vous le savez peut-être aussi un petit
un petit clin d'œil d'histoire les
prochains Jeux de Paris en 1921 2024
pardon seront mes premiers jeux de
l'histoire de la parité premier jeu de
l'histoire de 1924 à Paris seront les
premiers jeux où il y aura la parité au
niveau des participants entre les hommes
et les femmes
donc l'histoire de cette statue
en 2013 une amie à moi qui s'appelle
Béatrice Barbusse que certains
connaissent peut-être qui est une grande
femme
sociologue écrivaine qui a écrit un
livre qui s'appelle le sexisme dans le
sport mais également ancien nom de
balleuse
vice-président de la Fédération
Française de Handball va voir Denis
macellia denima Célia était à l'époque
le président du Comité Olympique et
Sportif Français
on lui demandant
quand est-ce qu'on va rendre hommage à
l'ISH Milla au sein du CNOSF
petit rien
il savait un petit peu mais c'est qui
[Musique]
septembre 2017 la France en l'occurrence
Paris gagne les Jeux Olympiques
en tout cas les Olympiques de 2024
et donc le regard s'inverse un peu
puisque c'est la patrie d'Alice Mia les
initiés savaient que les jeux de 24
seraient les jeux de la parité puisque
le comité olympique a mis en place tout
un système pour que de manière mécanique
on est de plus en plus de parité
aujourd'hui et on se retrouve en 2024
100 ans pile poil 100 ans après le
combat d'Alice Mila d'avoir les jeux
chez nous et là une autre femme
importante du mouvement sportif Emmanuel
brune
co-président de la FSGT
entre temps
bonjour est-ce qu'on peut comment on
peut faire pour rendre hommage à
l'ismillah voilà un petit peu plus de
d'obligation
puisque
il a dit ok bon on va faire un
commission qui va envisager comment
rendre hommage par une œuvre d'art au
sein du nouveau monde olympique mais
surtout pas une statue il faut pas faire
d'ombre à rond
laquelle je participe et pendant 18 mois
on fait des formations des conférences
aux élèves de l'école d'art appliqués
Olivier de Serres à Paris pour qu'ils
s'approprient un peu l'univers du sport
de l'olympisme et du sport féminin qui
avait des sociologues des athlètes des
historiens et moi-même et au bout de 18
mois
il nous propose trois œuvres d'art à une
en bois une envers une
en plaques
trois statuts
de la même taille que celle de Coubertin
donc qui est assez imposante
bon nous on dit ouais chouette super on
retourne voir le président de
l'Universités
à l'époque c'était évident que obertin
égale 1 = femme donc statut gaz statue
et là encore petit petit coup du destin
de nimassiglia est en touché par limite
d'âge ne pouvait pas se représenter pour
l'élection pour reprendre pour une 34e
élection au comité
on y va voilà et comme ça que cette
tuile a été inaugurée
le 8 mars 2021 sera dû être en 2019
mettre le covid pour c'est bien que
c'était des galets de fois et c'était un
immense odeur et symboliquement c'est
très important
à l'ismillah accueille les gens quand on
rentre un pixel qui accueille
alors pourquoi créer une fondation
c'est pour répondre effectivement aux
inégalités de médiatisation du sport
féminin et on l'a vu que comme
dernièrement pendant les Jeux Olympiques
de Tokyo de Pékin pour se construire
l'euro de foot féminin l'été dernier
quand c'est bien travaillé que c'est
bien filmé il y a un engouement
incroyable mais encore beaucoup trop
rare
ça a été effectivement un long chemin
pendant que c'est beaucoup trop rare
donc j'ai créé cette association d'abord
une association puis une fondation et on
lui a donné le nom d'Alice Mia compte
tenu de ce que je vous ai raconté plus
haut il nous fallait un rôle modèle il
fallait symboliser un peu ce combat et
c'est pourquoi d'avoir un créne une
fondation une association puis on a eu
la chance de rencontrer la fondation du
sport français qui nous a proposé de
créer une fondation donc une fondation
permet de lever de l'argent faire appel
à l'épargne public puisqu'il n'existait
pas en France
des renseignements pris pas en Europe et
une seule autre dans le monde aux
États-Unis par créer une année 70 par
Billy jenking qui était une femme qui
s'est battue dans les 70 sur le
l'égalité des cinq des salaires dans le
tennis donc un biopic est sorti il y a
pas très longtemps pour ceux qui ont un
peu le sport de près
oui après effectivement la question qui
vient souvent après qu'on me pose c'est
qui suis-je en tant qu'homme pour créer
une fondation parlons du sport féminin
je pense que tout le monde ça a été posé
c'est un homme qui vient pour parler
ma première ma première réflexe quand on
m'a posé cette question c'était
conscience et action
pour détailler ça il va falloir que je
vous parle un tout petit peu de moi mon
parcours de vie puisque c'est un peu le
résultat d'un parcours de vie comme je
le disais tout à l'heure c'est aussi mon
histoire
il y a une dizaine d'années j'ai 61 ans
j'ai eu la fameuse crise du milieu de
vie qui arrive un peu beaucoup de
personnes
et ma vie était bon c'était un petit peu
un peu un peu chamboulé
chez entrepris à cette époque là un
travail de guérison comme on dit en
train de guérison intérieure
psychologique physique émotionnel et
infinie spirituelle j'avais également à
cette époque là une société marketing
sportif qui a fermé
dans laquelle j'avais essayé de
développer le sport féminin et j'ai
aussi déposé le bilan donc c'était
vraiment vrai
les échiracs les emmerdes arrivent en
escadré donc j'ai pris l'escadrer le
plein fouet
et je me suis rendu compte que 1 c'était
quelque chose qui me portait
le sport la place de la femme dans le
sport et la place la fin de la société
et fallait malheureusement en faire une
cause de la création de la fondation
cette double action CFA double travail
c'est double vie à la fois développement
d'une fondation et
psychothérapie puisque entre temps j'ai
changé une troisième fois de métier je
suis revenu à ma formation de base
m'a fait
au quotidien de mettre en œuvre sa
conscience et action
et j'essaye de enfin je pense participer
à un vrai mouvement de fond qui est une
mouvement mondial je suis pas le seul et
bien heureusement de tentatives de
changer de polarité un petit peu dans ce
monde tout le monde assez
ces matérialiste c'est comment
rééquilibrer les tendances matérialistes
et égotiques
je dirais même guerrière de la société
patriarcale
qui consiste à valoriser la force à
valoriser le
l'adversité
la domination sur tout ce qui nous
entoure le remplacer par l'amour et la
bienveillance donc ça c'est quelque
chose qui me qui me qui me coûte et
pour moi effectivement la place de la
femme est importante au sujet là
Stone nous disait femme c'est vous qui
tenez entre vos mains le salut du monde
j'adhère complètement à cette citation
et je
parce que les femmes ont
incarner se rééquilibrage pour ma part
c'est je considère que c'est une plus
grande imposture de tous les temps que
notre société en effet descente et
citoyens de demeure
sont les gardiens de la nature
elles sont les gardiens du vivant du
mystère
le jour où l'homme a cessé de respecter
cela il s'est perdu et il a un équilibre
a été rompu
vous l'avez bien compris
je fais partie de ceux qui pensent que
les femmes sont la clé de ce qui se joue
en ce moment sur la terre dans ce monde
dans le combat qui oppose la vie
à sa destruction
elle doit être impérativement être connu
et le dalaï-lama ne s'est pas trompé en
confiant dernièrement d'une interview
qui voudrait voir une femme du succédé
je prends ces mots je souhaite je pense
qu'il serait bon d'avoir une fin comme
leader car voyez-vous bien logiquement
une ferme la plus aptitude à développer
l'empathie et l'autre
un peu ma vie mais c'était je vais
conclure par une une autre citation de
William Golding contre prix Nobel de
littérature en 1983
qui commence comme ça les femmes sont
folles
les femmes sont folles
lorsqu'elles prétendent d'être légal de
l'homme elles sont tout à fait
supérieures ils vont toujours été
elles magnifie et multiplie tout ce que
vous lui donnez
une phrase est résumé
on pourrait répondre au sujet qui nous
importe la place la fin la place de la
femme dans le sport je dirais que la
place c'est quelle place on veut donner
dans la ferme dans la société le sport
doit permettre effectivement de montrer
l'exemple grâce à ses valeurs
d'effort de bienveillance d'accueil
et c'est le vrai sujet et je vais
revenir sur ce que je vous disais donc
vous comprenez pourquoi j'ai fait cette
fondation conscience et action ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que quand on
prend on prend conscience de quelque
chose dans le on le met en action dans
ce quotidien s'il y a pas d'action c'est
qu'il y a pas de prise de conscience
pour ma part
j'ai pris cette prise de conscience je
passe beaucoup de temps sur cette
fondation
je crée cette fondation je la structure
et je permets aux femmes de la magnifier
et d'être en complémentarité que ce soit
un vrai succès
et je serai toujours là à leurs côtés
merci pour votre écoute que l'amour vous
guide et vous protège
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]